علينا ان نتذكر انه من الان وللابد كسرت
نظريه او عقيده الابن القوم الاسرائيلي
كانوا يتكلمون عن استخبارات
نافذه في بعض ربما طغيانهم في الحديث
قالوا اننا يعني نعلم ما يدور في حجرات
نوم الزعماء
العرب
[موسيقى]
ا
لابد ان اعترف لك ان بوتين كما لو انه رجل
فضاء لكنه حبط على سطح الشمس فوجئنا بانه
يتقدم من على الحدود البيلاروسيه يقترب
اليوم ويحتل تشرنوبل او يسيطر على
تشرنوبل كان على اكتافنا عبء كبير يوم كسر
سيفنا في يونيو 67 وقام هذا الشعب العظيم
يلملم سيفنا معنا ودعمنا وحتى يعبر معنا
عندما عبرنا في السادس من
اكتوبر
هناك جرائم حرب واباده ستصل الجميع من
اطراف قوات الاسد هناك صور تنقل على
الهواء لمن يشعل فتيل احد القنابل
البرميليه بيعود قاب او ربما بنيران
سيجارته هذه موثقه الى اين نحن
[موسيقى]
ذاهبون
انا اعتقد انهم اصيبوا اصابه بالغه لم
يشهدوها في تاريخهم دعني اقول لك ان
الثلاثه ايام
الاولى ان يقتحم الفلسطينيين بهذا الاداء
الرائع السياج الحدودي في اكثر من 80 صغره
وفي تقريبا سب معابر رئيسيه ان يصلوا
الى الى مستوطنه رعيم حيث مقر قياده فرقه
غزه وان ربما يصروا ضباط كبار فيها ربما
بدماس
[موسيقى]
النوم